Senator Biden it's nice to have you here
as the youngest member of the Senate the
one therefore who may expect the longest
career there I wonder if you'd say to us
since it's clear that you're not corrupt
and you got elected why should people
think that the system produces corrupt
results when there you are
well I'm not sure you should assume I'm
not corrupt but I'm thank you for that
though
what up yo I'm Dave Rubin the
non-corrupt Dave Reuben it's July 11
2023 you're watching the Reuben report
on the computer machine we're live
streaming on Rumble locals and YouTube
tap the Subscribe button if you have not
and as always you can join us for a post
game show to clean up the mess at
reubenreport.locals.com uh I'm being
told you have a question for me right up
top is that what's happening I'm going
to ask a question your I guess the team
this is on the Fly people I don't know
what's happening right now it's a
Tuesday test uh the team wants to ask me
a question do you want me to just read
this question myself they've put a
question on the prompter the question is
what kind of African is Whoopi Goldberg
you guys trying to get me canceled you
know you work for me if I go down you
all go down what kind of question is
that what kind of African is Whoopi
Goldberg African-American
what kind of question is this
I would say Whoopi Goldberg what kind of
African like oh I see what country in
Africa did Whoopi Goldberg's ancestors
come from
I don't know how about Chad how about
Chad
no not Chad uh her ancestors are from
the African country of Guinea Busa
or bissau
I've enjoyed doing this program and it
was nice knowing all of you goodbye
what are we doing uh
the theme of today's show uh guys the
woke are not going anywhere and we're
gonna have to separate from them we're
going to have to build our new things as
I always say uh and we just have to keep
Paving those roads so as more and more
people wake up they can join us uh in
our sanity party uh and it's really the
last 48 hours across disciplines uh it
has just gone completely crazy with
these walksters and I think we're
getting close to moving a couple people
yeah the old Bill Maher types the old
Joe Rogan types uh as I mentioned to you
guys yesterday on Sunday I interviewed
RFK Jr part one of that will be going up
on YouTube and Rumble today the full uh
hour plus interview with him will be on
locals today ad free and all that good
stuff but I think a whole bunch of
people are now seeing it I even asked
RFK about it like that the Democrat
Party perhaps is not redeemable at least
anytime soon and that there really is a
new path that should be blazed so that
is the theme for today and uh any other
questions for me before we get to it
anything else you want to throw me
where's Sunny from good God
you people depend on me for jobs don't
you know that
let's talk about Mike box real quick
you guys know that 60 of U.S pork
production comes from one company owned
by the Chinese and their Hogs are given
something called raktip of bean which is
banned in 160 countries including China
but not uh what was the country she's
from but so
but not Guinea but so I'm pretty sure uh
yet you find it in your grocery aisle
every day well guys there's a better way
and I want to tell you about moink
that's move plus and oink Mike delivers
grass-fed and grass-finished beef and
lamb pastured pork and chicken and
sustainable wild caught alaskans
straight to your door you choose the
meat delivered in every box like Ribeyes
chicken breasts the pork chops the
salmon fillets and much more plus you
can cancel anytime there's nothing
better than cooking there filet mignon
on my big green egg on a Friday evening
Shark Tank host Kevin O'Leary called
moink's bacon the best bacon he's ever
tasted and they guarantee you'll say
oink oink I'm just so happy I got
moinked I could probably put a whoopie
joke in there too but here we go
keep American farming going by signing
up at moinkbox.com Reuben right now and
listeners of this show get free ground
beef for a year that's one of the best
ground beef you'll ever taste but for a
limited time and now back to me so on
those lefties that are on the way and
you gotta drag them and they're slow and
they have their luxury beliefs and they
kind of get some stuff right but they
never kind of get there of course the
guy at the top of that list uh is Bill
Maher but I'm going to keep nudging him
appropriately uh Bill Maher had uh Jon
Hamm on the show you guys know Hollywood
actor Jon Hamm and they got into it
about what's going on with the woke and
and what the good liberals can do
related to all of this and uh I think
Bill said something here that makes some
sense
and I keep basically the same philosophy
for 30 years even though the politics
changes so my audience sometimes changes
I mean I've lost a fair number of of
this what I would call the super woke
and it's good don't let the door hit you
in the ass you were no fun to begin with
you have a terrible sense of humor yeah
uh I think that's don't you think you
tell me because you have a little more
of a sense of what the mood in the rooms
so to speak is but I feel like that
particular Affliction is waning in some
way it because it feels like it's
reached its useful
conclusion the critical mass is like
okay we get it
we get it there's there is a useful
quality to some of what you're saying
the over the reaction correct
overbearing thing of it is absolutely
not useful and in fact it's counter it's
counterproductive to your own point I'm
shooting yourself in the foot and then
wondering why you walk with them maybe
this is a wave that's coming but the
fact that
um a few people have stood out and did
that to me just I don't know these
people are not going away
yeah this idea that they're not going
away I've been saying it for quite some
time right what we can do is we can wake
up some people we all know all of you
watching this right now you know some
friends or family members that maybe
there's still a little flicker there
they've gone kind of woke or they're
into some of this stuff but they're not
like completely over the board hacking
away at their genitals yet and maybe you
can still save them but the point is the
the structure of this thing and by the
way Jon Hamm who's just a Hollywood
actor so I don't think you have to pay
that much attention generally to What
actors say uh he did sort of get that
right there meaning that for whatever
good intentions these people had right
whether we all think they're good
intentions or not or whatever that
they've they've sort of jumped the shark
so to speak right like it's just too
much at this point so it's good to see
someone from Hollywood again whether you
like Jon Hammer or not whether you have
I don't know much about his political
beliefs or anything else I didn't even
watch what was that show he was in the
the show about the advertising agency in
the madman I didn't even watch Mad Men
so I don't even know much about the guy
but the point is that someone in
Hollywood is like oh you worksters have
kind of gone too far it's actually
counterproductive at this point so he's
right and Bill's right that also the
movement itself
is not going to go anywhere and if you
want proof that the movement is not
going to go anywhere you might you just
need look at what the corporate press is
constantly throwing at us and how no
matter how hysterical it gets like boys
or girls everyone's racist blah all that
stuff it always gets crazier uh this is
what was going on yesterday here's a
tweet from
MSNBC the far right obsession with
Fitness is going digital opinion why the
far right is really into Home Fitness
white supremacists latest scheme to
valorize violence and Hyper masculinity
has gone digital now we've seen things
like this before that's not the first
time that we've shown you a headline
like that you you know from Salon or
Rolling Stone or something like that and
it sort of related to what I mentioned
yesterday how you know UFC these
Fighters boxers kickboxers all of these
people they seem to be a bit outspoken
right now and they're usually anti-woke
because they care about meritocracy they
care about working hard that's connected
to Fitness it's like go get yours be in
the best body that you can be in right
like there's a there's a beauty of that
there's competition which is very
counter to equity Equity we will all end
up in the same place so you can see the
machine is very concerned that if you
care about Fitness if you watch that
scary Joe Rogan with his big muscles
you're going to become far right it
really means absolutely nothing Joe
Rogan wasn't really having it he tweeted
out this
he retweeted the article and he wrote
being healthy is far right holy so
that's Joe Rogan's feelings on it uh but
you can see this is what they do with
literally everything if a new trend
comes out and that new trend lends
itself like working out does to you
taking care of yourself and eating right
and not being reliant on the machine and
not just sitting there with something
strapped to your nuts eating bugs while
you're in Zuckerberg's metaverse that's
not really good for them and by the way
this has been going on for quite some
time a tweet by end wokeness who I
reference on the show quite often uh the
regime wants you fat docile weak and
compliant and of course what you can see
there is the cover of Cosmopolitan
magazine with an obese woman and they're
telling us that she's healthy uh you can
see the ad on the right and we've seen
this in what what ad is that that's
Calvin Klein right and we've seen many
other of these types of things and you
can see why is it just again you just
have to think about it at the base level
you don't have to think about it too
hard why are they pushing
boys or girls racism is good fat is good
and not only those things but if you are
fit you're also in essence racist it's
to just keep you dumb and dependent on
them that's really it but there's a
whole set of these people not only at
the corporate level who always push it
but you know of course at the political
level uh here's video of noted bisexual
Canadian Prime Minister Justin Trudeau
here he is in Latvia lecturing his own
troops about climate change
climate change is having a real
destabilizing and negative impact
with more and more frequent extreme
weather events
at home
and as challenging as it is at home
impacts around the world where people
are in more precarious economic and
Geographic situations than we are
that's a new reality that has huge
implications for security around the
world which is one of the reasons why
Canada is stepping up to build the
center of excellence for climate
security
in Montreal that's one of the
announcements we're going to be making
tomorrow at at the NATO Summit guys
Canada's building the center for
excellence for climate security oh my
God Justin Trudeau look at my socks
can you imagine being a Canadian citizen
who uh voluntarily signs up for the
military right and Canada is not known
as a country that's going to send its
troops all over the place and blow up a
whole bunch of stuff or anything like
that then they send you to Latvia
there's not a lot going on in Latvia
you're stationed in Latvia having a nice
Latvian Orthodox lunch and what are they
going to do to you they send that
ridiculous buffoon to lecture you about
climate change and by the way guys that
will be very connected to the next round
of Wars once they finish up World War
III with this Ukraine thing we will have
climate Wars and God knows what else I
just can't imagine truly like joking
aside like you're you're a member of the
Canadian military they send you you know
half the world away and you have to
listen to that guy talk about how he's
going to set up some conference where
they're going to somehow stop the
climate
from changing as if this guy can do
anything other than lock down his own
people and close their bank accounts
which he's quite good at but it's not
just of course Justin Trudeau it is
virtually everyone on the political left
throughout the Western world one of the
worst Governors that we have in the
United States uh not quite as bad as
Gavin Newsom but you know she's she's
trying is Kathy hochul of New York Kathy
who of course took over after they
kicked out Andrew Cuomo then she did get
reelected because the people of New York
are obviously masochists well don't
worry uh she is very concerned about
climate change and she's very very
concerned about the thing that causes
climate change starts with a C but it's
not the C that she is it's capitalism
here by local leaders to give an update
on
the current situation what we're
anticipating going forward
and what residents need to do together
how we can stand up
and it using every bit of our power
mobilizing to fight the ravages of
climate change because again these are
unprecedented weather events that keep
hitting us over and over and over again
so we must change our Behavior
as a planet
as a country as a state and in our own
homes we're going to continue that
conversation and Earnest because we have
to know
that we have to do everything in our
power to protect our citizens
Jesus lady can you find out what's the
uh like when when someone like her drops
dead one day and with the amount of
Botox and filler in her face what does
that do to the environment we're going
to work on that but but putting that
aside for a moment everything she said
there was complete nonsense there these
extreme weather events that are
happening in New York sometimes it rains
in New York sometimes it's storms in New
York it happens to have been a very nice
summer so far in New York I've got a lot
of family and still still in New York I
don't know why I'm trying to get them
down here but people you know it is what
it is
um but do you see what she says we're
gonna have to figure it out as a
community and a state and a country and
in our homes and then they will come for
your gas stoves and literally people in
New York will be freezing in the winter
and burning hot in the summer because
they will limit what AC you can use what
heat you can use everything else and as
if as even if New York Let's Pretend any
of this was real Let's Pretend climate
change is real or any of this stuff
imagine if every single person in New
York did absolutely everything they
basically never used heat they never
used air conditioning imagine if they
didn't use gas stoves they all recycled
perfectly they did whatever it is
they didn't eat meat right all the stuff
they did whatever it is these lunatics
like her want completely unscientific
but let's imagine every single New
Yorker did it do you know how much it
would affect the environment
zero it would do absolute jack
nothing and she knows that the only
reason they're doing this is because
they want to figure out new ways to
control you new ways for you to stay in
your house when they want you to stay in
your house and knock it in your car
because it's a gas guzzler and not eat
these certain things but but just know
that she will always do it and we'll
have evidence of how some of the elites
behave on their own uh when they are
doing their own thing they're telling us
to eat bugs and stay at home but they
still get on their Yachts don't worry
about that but it's not just her it's
not just her this is this guy this is
the king of the climate this is the
climate King himself John Kerry he was
asked a question on MSNBC about the
Ukraine war this was his answer
the the climate crisis is growing by the
day you just saw have reported on what
happened in New York all around the
world there are record-breaking days
where the heat is greater than it's ever
been before this will be the hottest
June and July it'll be the hottest
summer it'll be the hottest year and we
all know that because the science is
telling it to us and because Mother
Earth is responding by telling us
exactly what's going on guys trust the
science and Mother Earth he looks like
he might date Mother Earth you know why
because he looks like ant you remember
ant from Lord of the Rings this guy that
is
I am I am
he looks like yeah that's what he looks
like to me um he's half tree maybe
that's why he's trying to save the
environment I'm trying to I'm trying to
be nice here he's trying to save the
environment because he's half tree
Connor you had somebody else that you
thought you looked like right
who who is this I don't know who this is
from what
this is someone do we know this guy's
name
this is Moonlight man from a movie
called Gerald's Game which apparently is
a Stephen King book yeah yeah so he does
look like John Kerry that actually might
be John Kerry doing his one acting they
took the makeup off John Kerry's face
and that's what he actually looks like
anyway you get the point guys everything
they ask him a question about Ukraine
and it's oh it's hot in New York in the
summer you're not going to believe this
guys I walked Clyde this morning and uh
it's July in Florida and I came back and
I was sweating it was wild I was like oh
my what what is this what is this do we
miss coming off my forehead it's hot in
the summer in Florida I can't believe it
but yes they're they're just they're all
Extraordinary artists John
Kerry flies everywhere private Kathy
hochel flies everywhere private and the
King John Kerry is the king of climate
crap basically but but the king of like
Hollywood climate
catastrophizing is absolutely Leonardo
DiCaprio This is great this is from
disclosed TV on Twitter uh La Dolce Vita
in Italy for visits to the countryside
for lunch dinner or disco climate
activist Leonardo DiCaprio likes to take
the helicopter from his luxury yacht
build report so look at that luxury
yacht I've never been on a yacht like
that you guys ever been a you're not
like that no we're going to rent a
Reuben report yacht and get out there so
he takes a helicopter he doesn't even
get on a little dinghy he could get on a
dinghy and take it so that he could have
lunch but no he takes a helicopter which
burns a lot of fuel and a yacht Burns a
lot of fuel and just imagine the foods
they are eating on this thing they are
all liars and they lie and they cheat
and they steal when it comes to
everything and speaking of lying and
cheating and stealing as you know the
big story of last week in the tech world
was that Facebook
Meta Meta is the parent company it's not
called Facebook anymore it's called meta
which basically owns Facebook Instagram
they have now spun off their new uh app
called threads which is a Twitter clone
uh and Elon Musk is not happy about this
because they've hired a bunch of people
from Twitter who had signed ndas and
possibly took information that they
weren't allowed to bring to a new
company a little bit on uh from Twitter
daily news on this uh Twitter is
threatening to sue meta over systematic
willful and unlawful misappropriation of
Twitter's Trade Secrets and IP as well
as scraping Twitter's data in a cease
and desist letter sent yesterday to
Zuckerberg by elon's lawyer Alex Spiro
to which Elon Musk replied competition
is fine cheating is not now you might be
wondering Dave how are you how are you
connecting this to what we're talking
about earlier what does this have to do
with the environment stuff and threads
and all that the point is
they lie about everything whether it's
Trade Secrets whether it's censorship I
mean imagine the type of person imagine
the type of person that after all of
these years of covid and election lies
and everything that the media has lied
about you go to the new site created by
the guy Mark Zuckerberg who has admitted
working with the government silencing
people and you're like oh that's the
site I'm going to go to he's literally
it's just so extraordinary I I genuinely
don't understand the mindset of someone
like this I mean I guess I get it at a I
get it at a completely disconnected
level but at a personal level I don't
understand it like you have a guy who is
saying we are creating a new Twitter
clone because there's too much free
speech there's too many people saying
what they want now you don't have to
listen to people you can block people
you can mute people but there's too many
people sharing ideas over there so come
to the place that we will censor it for
you this is what the Matrix is guys this
is the blue pill this is why ignorance
is bliss they want you to be dumb and
fat and happy because you will have no
concept of what reality is you will also
not own anything that's a big one with
them but they lie about absolutely
everything now let's get to the media
component of it here is the televised
mental institution MSNBC with noted
racist Joy Reed and she's railing
against Elon and Free Speech gosh darn
it that free speech with those people
saying what they want to say
Twitter might be on the slow road to
obscurity as Mark Zuckerberg's rival app
threads has surpassed 100 million users
in only five days meanwhile Twitter
users are mostly left with a ranting and
raving Elon Musk and lots and lots of
races you have Neo-Nazi Richard Spencer
allowed to host Twitter spaces and polls
like this anti-semitic one asking if
Jews control the world and are Waging
War on white Western Society
um those are being allowed to stay up
horrifyingly half of the people who
engaged with this tweet answered yes to
that question
it's just one example of Twitter failing
to regulate hate speech from their dues
paying blue checks who are also
spreading misinformation with a new
report showing that blue checks are
fueling disinformation about the Ukraine
war blue checks are fueling
disinformation she'd know a bit about
disinformation as she is one of the
biggest disinformation uh agents in the
United States now you might watch those
things that guy Elijah Shafer who put up
that poll about Jews I know Elijah he
used to be at the blaze years ago uh
like I don't like the idea of putting up
a poll like that also people just
respond on Twitter like to troll things
they just put up yes it's the Jews like
there's just a trolling nature to the
internet I'm not defending it or
condemning it actually but the question
is do you want a place where people can
just go and be dicks and and
also interesting and clever and
sarcastic and messy and all of those
things already which right like that's
what I would want right and I think
that's that's what the principle of free
speech is all about if if someone goes
on Twitter and says some really noxious
thing you have every ability to say
something noxious back to them right or
they can block you or you can block them
you can curate it to your own likes and
and wants right like I'm I am a free
speech absolutist in that sense
sometimes people say horrible things to
me on Twitter I just block them like
that's not infringing on anyone's Free
Speech but I don't have to partake in
your craziness what Joy read and people
like her want is they don't want anyone
to share any opinion that is outside of
of what they deem is okay so I'm not
defending that poll I'm not defending
any of the noxious things people might
say I'm defending their ability to say
it and she's very upset that people are
allowed to say these things and it and
you can see it's so interesting what's
happening here remember when Elon Musk
bought Twitter and suddenly there were
all these articles out of nowhere there
were all these articles about how
Twitter has a child porn problem so for
years before Twitter uh was bought by
Elon Musk nobody talked about the child
porn problem on Twitter right then he
gets it and then suddenly they're all
saying Twitter has a child porn problem
now he's done a tremendous amount about
that they don't write much about that
but he's is actually trying to deal with
it where Twitter before was not doing
anything but you they show their cards
sometimes it's like well why weren't you
concerned about child porn before none
of the somebody did a study on this none
of the authors who wrote any of these
articles about Elon Musk and Twitter
childhorn had written anything pre-elod
musk so they pick when they care about
certain issues it's just rather
extraordinary and now I want to show you
unfortunately a video from The View I
thought maybe we could take a day off
but then this Anna Navarro she does not
like Elon Musk and uh she is blaming him
for you people thinking differently than
she does
I I joined too because it's not owned by
Elon Musk and that in itself is enough
for me to join I you know I just I don't
understand how somebody with as much
money as Elon Musk as many children as
Elon Musk as many projects as Elon Musk
uh can be so have so much time to be
trolling and spreading hate and
misinformation on this platform that
went from going downhill to going right
off the cliff you know I mean this guy
can he just maybe go to space do you
stay there do you think you know I mean
I just I you know I I I I hate what's
happening to Twitter because I think
Twitter has done a lot of good I think
there's a lot of movements around the
world that have happened because of of
Twitter and it's you know it's done a
lot of good it's also done a lot of bad
and um but he has no intention of
stopping the lies and the misinformation
the the incredible condescending tone
and resentment she has were probably the
most important person that is on Earth
right now someone that is literally
trying to get us to do interplanetary
travel someone who's doing a hell of a
lot for the environment someone who is
buying a thing like Twitter which is
losing a ton of money bought it for
what was it a cool 45 billion dollars
knowing it was losing a crazy amount of
money but he bought it because he wanted
to defend Free Speech misinformation was
being peddled left and right all over
Twitter and censorship was running
rampant Oliver Twitter Hunter Biden's
story for example the laptop you
couldn't even share it on your private
DMS New York Post got banned on Twitter
even though it now has all turned out to
be true he came in and said hey we will
defend the principles of Free Speech but
there is an entire
machine devoted to making you think that
truth and questions and curiosity and
thinking about the world in a different
way is all bad and negative and is hate
and you can see it whether it's Anna
Navarro you can see it whether it's Joy
read or it's Karin Jean-Pierre or
virtually anybody that is part of the
machine at this point the I also what
she says the condescending tone he has
all this money he has all these children
he has all these projects like yeah so
he's trying to defend Free Speech
Because he believes in the future right
his kids he could put them all on a
rocket and get them all off this Rock
right now he's probably thinking about
it because of you morons
anywho let's do one more clip of the
view and then I have a special
announcement related to The View coming
up in just a second The View had a
particularly insane segment yesterday I
know it's just like it's it really is
just insane what they're doing every day
over there but as you know
um Hunter Biden had a affair with some
woman and has another grandchild a
seventh grandchild there has been a
court case hung up because Hunter Biden
wants nothing to do with this kid and
does not want this kid to have the Biden
name and apparently the court has upheld
that decision and now the bidens meaning
Joe Biden and Dr Jill Biden are
basically saying they are going to have
nothing to do with this kid who will not
have their last name try to imagine
something so profoundly evil that
they're throwing their own grandchild it
is their grandchild it is Hunter Biden's
child nobody is doubting that they are
they are erasing this child from history
these evil evil people now listen to the
ladies on The View defend in essence
they're sort of Defending 100 they're
really defending Joe Biden as if he has
no uh no connectivity to this child
watch this
scarring is one of his grandchildren's
lives by not publicly embracing her so
apparently
his son
had a baby with a woman they've thought
about it and he pays for the for the
baby but he has not embraced the child
so Maureen down is saying it's bad for
the child that the president has not
acknowledged her
so I
I kind of think well that's a she should
be clutching at the son whose baby it is
it's not the president's baby so I don't
know what you think but I'm throwing it
out I agree with you completely it
shouldn't have been uh it's uh
directed to Joe Biden should be directed
to Hunter Biden it's five children not
four Hunter because this is not Joe
Biden's baby and I think it's very hard
for Joe Biden to be a grandfather to the
child if his son is not being a father
he can talk to his child he can advise
Hunter but look what is what is
absolutely evident to me is that the
right wing and the Maga world has
decided to weaponize Hunter Biden
against his dad yeah and everything and
anything Hunter does or does not do is
going to be weaponized and Marine
doubted yeah she's a very serious
these are such bad people I don't know
what I always say it's like I don't know
what else I can say in some of these
cases there's so much nonsense first off
Joe Biden every day every day we played
a clip of him saying it yesterday says
these are all our children doesn't he
these are all our children Hillary
Clinton it takes a village but somehow
Joe Biden's own grandchild is not his
son's child in essence and he can't have
anything to do with him why can't let's
say you have a son who's a crack addict
and a lunatic and a criminal and blah
blah blah whatever things Hunter Biden
may or may not be but let's say you have
a son who's just like a complete psycho
often grandparents end up taking care of
that kid they are making sure they have
nothing to do with this kid and this kid
will not have the Biden name now imagine
this was Trump Jr imagine if Donald
Trump Jr had been smoking crack bang
some random woman had a kid with her and
then did not want that kid to have the
Trump name imagine what these insane
harpies would be saying about that they
are so profoundly dishonest and that
what the what's the real problem here
the real problem isn't that Hunter Biden
isn't going to be a father to this kid
and it's not that Joe Biden and Jill
Biden with all of the resources that
they have at their fingertips will have
nothing to do with this kid and they're
stealing the child's Birthright from him
which is his last name they're stealing
that from him too who's the real bad guy
here of course it's the right wing it's
the Republicans who are weaponizing this
against the family God you women are
just awful and on that note I have
decided officially today
to announce the worst of the view hosts
this has been an ongoing thing it's
almost impossible there's no way to do
this right and it's completely
subjective I suppose but I have to do it
so so I'm going to try to go this is not
in any particular order but at the end
I'll tell you the one that's the worst
so look it's not Whoopi it's not Whoopi
whoopee it is sad what she has become
she's sort of like this odd Jabba the
Hutt type figure who you know we once
loved from you know all her great movies
and stand up and doing stuff with Robin
Williams and Billy Crystal and there was
something really good there with Whoopi
right and it's unfortunate and She's
Stoned every day and just stupid and she
doesn't know what she's saying okay fine
I'm not gonna say it's whooping because
there was a nugget of goodness there Joy
Behar I despite everything despite Joy
Behar when the Ukraine war broke out she
was very upset that her trip to Italy
was going to be you plan a trip to Italy
for months and then the war breaks out
like she's just awful she but she once
was an awful I Used to Know her a bit on
the upper west side we would say hi all
the time she'd play with my dog for a
second and her husband and so it's not
it's not
Joy
then you got your now I know who so it's
I can see where you guys are going it's
not Alyssa Farah by the way Alyssa Faris
so she's the conservative right Alyssa
Farah now she's just a sellout there's
nothing you can say about her like she's
just if Alyssa Farah probably is the
most Pleasant of all of them because
she's somewhat conservative leaning
she's probably not an absolutely
horrible human but she took the money to
just sell out all of her beliefs for a
bunch of people that'll throw her under
the bus one day but that doesn't make
her the worst so now we've got two left
right well then there's that other
blonde that nobody knows right so we're
just going to toss her away nobody knows
who she is is she even on the show
whoever the hell she is doesn't matter
so you've got two and now this is what
you're all wondering because we're all
thinking of the thing the same thing
Dave who who is it how do you choose who
is worse between Sunny Hosten and Anna
Navarro and I'm gonna shock everybody
right now I'm going to shock everybody I
I think Anna Navarro is actually the
worst Sonny Hosten is the most unlikable
uh unpleasant condescending uh snarky
vicious
creature that's on television she really
is there is nothing likeable about her
um she she's so the way she looks at the
guests and the co-hosts just the
condescension that's the thing with her
but it is what it is with her so you
know what it is right you don't have to
wonder about her at all now Anna Navarro
and Anna just took over in the last
couple days Anna because everything she
says is a lie and is a complete
Distortion of everything she believed 10
years ago she used to work for Marco
Rubio she was saying but also because
she lives here in Florida she lives here
in the freest place literally in the
United States and literally in the world
she lives here and enjoys our freedom
and knows no one's coming for her as a
Latina and nobody's coming for her black
friends and nobody's coming for the gays
or anything else she is an obsessive
liar and horrible person and today I
award you Anna Navarro the worst host of
The View we should have do we have some
sort of can we do we have something that
we can do is there a ding a ding you got
a ding and that's all you deserve you
awful human being but let's continue on
this thing about the grandchild uh
because CNN
the news network it was it was well the
former News Network of CNN uh also
chimed in on the Biden grandchild
situation and of course yes they also
said that the real issue here is it's
being used by Republicans
you know this is
this is a story that is sad and
disturbing on so many levels
um yes it is political for a couple of
reasons
um number one yes Republicans are using
it and are going to take advantage of it
in a way that is unfortunate
inappropriate
number one it's Republicans that's the
real issue here guys number one because
this crackhead son of the
dementia-ridden president had a child
out of wedlock with some other chicken
now they don't want anything to do with
the child nor to use his last name or
anything but the number one issue is
that Republicans are gonna pounce on
that oh my God you people are
absolutely horrible and again the double
standard and the Trump Junior thing and
all that so let's Go full circle here I
think we've demonstrated that the woke
are radical that they are liars that
they are fakers and that they are wicked
people who seem to be getting worse and
worse I think that really is the key
thing here when Bill Maher says they're
not going anywhere I think we also have
to acknowledge that the base of them is
just going to continue uh to devolve so
my question is
is it yet time for the Joe Rogan's the
bill Mars the Elon musks everybody that
wake is seeing all of these things to
officially uh say what I have said which
is that you cannot be a Democrat anymore
or you can at least never vote for
Democrats you do not have to be a
republican but you cannot vote for a
Democrat right that is the point uh
we've got one more for you here uh well
let's just throw to it I've I've
explained a lot on the program today
here we go maybe that's true maybe this
is a wave that's coming but the fact
that
um a few people have stood out and did
that to me does I don't know these
people are not going away
so that's it to bring you full circle
they're not going away Bill's
acknowledging yeah a few people have
woke up it's nice to see John Hamm it's
nice to see someone from Hollywood wake
up but they will not stop and that's why
it's been such that's why someone like
Anna Navarro is is so dangerous to the
American discourse right because she
knowingly is lying about everything and
she's giving nobody an off ramp when she
runs around in that video we showed you
yesterday where she says when I'm in
Florida I put my head out the the window
like a dog and I yell gay and it's like
lady please I I you know the truth is
that's obviously not true she doesn't
put her head out the window like a dog
and yell gay although I did once see her
uh on the street in Coconut Grove
not too long ago but the point is when
she knowingly says these lies she's
adding fuel
to the fire of the people who want to
burn down this country who Who start
thinking that the good people who are
doing right are actually the bad people
and she's so out of whack with what's
going on here in Florida that she spends
all day long railing against a guy like
Ron DeSantis who is the most popular
politician in the history of Florida who
has run this place so that we have more
people moving here than ever more
tourism than ever it's safer than ever
our economy's stronger than ever and
everything else they will make you think
that up is down and left is right in
boys or girls
so as Bill said
we must separate from them but the
question is uh when you guys separate
will you vote the right way that the
answer to that remains to be seen ladies
and gentlemen that is our program for
today I would like to hear from some of
you guys about uh your worst host of The
View which which is the worst uh you can
join us on the post game show right now
at
reubenreport.locals.com Cold clothes and
we'll see everybody on the other side
the answer to the question everybody
wants to know LeBron what's your
decision
that was the conclusion you woke up with
this morning
[Music]
thank you